thank you uh peter we are here with
radoslav yadinyak uh the polish chess
federation president uh radoslav welcome
to the show tell us a little bit about
how difficult it is to put a tournament
of this magnitude together
well this is
this class of tournament it doesn't
happen very often and it's always
difficult and there's a lot of new new
things and new tasks uh some things you
have never done before
and this is this is just such a
prestigious event full of uh top players
it's not the first such tournament in
poland we had world championship we had
european championship over the last year
and there are so many uh
problems of course because we have so
many players
every player has
has its his own
um plans uh
wishes uh and you know it's it's it's a
long story and difficult thing uh i like
that the tournament takes place
especially here in the polish jewish
museum
and this is a this is especially uh nice
because it reminds us that we have great
a connection between polish and jewish
people
polish and jewish fought to
play it just together before the second
world war uh we both both nations uh we
won uh gold medal in chess olympiad in
hamburg 1930 and many other many other
great
results especially in chess olympiads
players like akiba robinstein
amigo naidov just to mention the most
important and the best players
of polish national team were of course
of jewish origins and that's great we're
playing in this absolutely quite a
wonderful place important and tell us a
bit you took over four years ago and
polish chess has pretty much exploded
how important it is to see two of your
best chess players uh do the and
voitershek participating against the
best chess players in the world yes they
are well today in vitash they are they
are well they work so hard that it was
quite obvious they will be in the in the
top of the world especially youngsters
of duda will just who will play the
candidates a tournament in madrid uh
just to to challenge magnus carson if if
possible uh well
i like well i like them playing here
another another tournament especially
such
such a big event as super bet by many
consider as the strongest tournament
ever played
in poland in poland this is possible
when you look at every trading this is
possible probably you have to calculate
it somehow but i think this is true very
close very close very close it must be
the strongest
event and uh
well that's that's great they are
playing here but this is not
like a gift they deserve playing in this
in this big tournament
but i also can't that
they will
lead polish national team to medal on
the chess olympiad
and how important it is for the younger
generation to have two leaders like
these two players spearheading the
revolution in polish chess that is
extremely important i remember as i'm
trust grant master i remember when when
i was young
and we didn't have such leader but still
we had some round robin tournaments with
even with anatoli kaiko with some
players
and i went to watch them live i wanted
to see the best players in the world
but they were not polish but now
young players they see dude and voitacic
who are polish and this must be a much
better boost and there is nothing uh
strange that this we have so many young
people starting address tens of
thousands new polish
players young
just five six seven eight years old uh
they started playing they they watched
duda and voitashak and they will be more
and more and in probably 10 years we'll
have another duda or
something like this well um probably in
the audience right now because the
theater is packed with young players as
well now i'm going to put you on the
spot before we go back into the games
who's your favorite to win this evening
dude
thank you very much i think he'll win
he's especially good
in rapid and with stress he is indeed
thank you very much for joining the show
thank you guys back to you thank you
christian i'd like to immediately